[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist this
is sports edition
and i got with me my co-host one of two
for this format chuck nice chuck how you
doing man hey man yeah sports edition
i'm the guy who
uh in whatever iteration of sports i'm
the guy bringing the water
is that what you do the gatorade
i'm the gatorade guy oh no that's me
hey how you doing you're thirsty
you need some electrolytes there buddy
squirt it into your mouth yeah
yeah exactly
gary o'reilly gary
from the uk
you're with us stateside now i think but
i am yes originally of the uk uh playing
professional soccer there yeah for
professional football i guess they could
go and you were an announcer there so
you're delighted to have both of those
features within you so gary just tell me
what you got up your sleeve for today um
something we take for granted neil
imagine surfaces
we we engage with so many every day
smartphones our clothing footwear
kitchens even paint
but what is happening at a molecular
level oh they're all disgusting that's
what's happening
they're all nasty all right well we'll
see if that's the case i mean
is it material science is it physical
chuck i didn't know you had such strong
opinions about molecules this is true
especially when they form bonds that
actually hurt me oh god and molecular
bonds okay go on gary all right so i
mean and then we'll get
to the friction which happens when
certain services connect and then
we have biomimicked so much from mother
nature and tried to recreate her work
and we've even taken these inventions
into space
so we'll go there as well um but really
right now what we need is someone who
could
make paint drying seem interesting and i
think what we have
is just the person so neil if you would
like to introduce our guest today then
uh we'll go from there well i'll be i'd
be happy to so we've got laurie winkles
laura did i pronounce that correctly
perfectly neal yeah well done excellent
you're coming to us with an irish accent
but at the moment you're in new zealand
very cool thank you thank you for for
hanging with us even though you're on
the other side of the earth
at some unholy time of day
in this interview because it's a regular
time of day for us
oh it's all good it's almost 9 a.m it's
all good
oh that's okay okay 9 a.m on tomorrow
yeah tomorrow in the future
[Laughter]
you have a background in physics and in
space and working in national labs uh
you're a science communicator
a lecturer i love it all you've got
books
uh one of them is called was it science
and the city is that one of your yeah
that was my first book
i love it a wonderful title
and uh most recently what's called
sticky the secret science of surfaces
and that sounds all about friction we've
done several shows talking about
friction in sports so
um this will fit right into that to that
portfolio so so let me let me just sort
of start off i think i got to start a
question i got for you so
um i think people want to know
about
gecko feet
[Music]
by the way is isn't that gekko from new
zealand
there is a gecko in new zealand and it's
a very unusual one because it lives in
the mountains it's an alpine gecko no i
i was talking about the geico gecko
oh no not him oh yeah what what accent
does the guy what absolutely does that
guy
he's in he's in east london he's you'll
know this lori there's a soap opera in
england called eastenders it's based in
the east end of london
yeah he is one of the cast members
uh and he's he's not putting on a voice
that's him that's him that's just him
although he's not great the gecko isn't
the the actor who is that voice is a
cast member yes not the gecko no i'm
sorry
because i said last time i saw east
standards i don't remember talking about
the gecko no yeah talking gekko would
make it a lot more interesting all right
well let's let's
all right lori let's unravel the gecko
um so i've got this right you've got
hairs on hairs on scales on toes on feet
yeah that's pretty much it actually gary
yeah the gecko foot is what we call a
hierarchical structure so what that
really means is that it has features of
different sizes that combine together to
to give the gecko its climbing super
power i suppose so
if you look at a little gecko's toes um
usually the toes themselves are pretty
strong so that's often enough to get
them to cling on to like a bark of a
tree or whatever just to be clear lori
i've never done this you said if you
look at a gecko's toe you've never
looked like a gecko's toes i'm sorry
yeah i understand that there's a fetish
i'll take a step back geckos usually
have four legs we'll start there they're
little lizards and they have depending
on their species like four or five toes
on each foot okay
so the thing about their toes is and
sometimes if you see them at maybe a zoo
or something if you see them on a glass
surface that's usually the best way to
get a real like insight into what's
going on
so you've got their little their little
feet
on their toes their toes are covered in
these flaps of skin and they're called
lamellae they're just stripes of skin
and for the longest time scientists you
know we just thought that that was it
was to do with those flaps of skin like
maybe they were acting as some sort of
like a suction cup or maybe you had when
they're yeah when they're pressed
against a flat surface they look they
look cute
nice yeah they flatten out so like that
was what we thought that was all we
thought that geckos could do but like as
microscopes began to
develop more and get better and better
and we could zoom in a bit further
like gary said we realized those flaps
of skin are actually covered in this
very very dense forest of hairs
and they're called ct so they're just
hairs
but they increase the surface area so
much so it's now not a flat bit of skin
it's a really heavily textured forest of
hairs
if you zoom in on the end of each of
those hairs you'll find that they
actually they each have like a really
bad case of split ends right so each one
of those hairs splays out into lots of
other smaller hairs
and the ends of those hairs can make
such intimate contact with surfaces now
when i mean intimate contact i mean
getting within one nanometer of the
molecules that make up the surface
so what you're saying is the surfaces we
might think are smooth but on the on the
very small level they're not so if you
have everything small enough
to get in the nooks and the crannies
especially the crannies
then
i don't know the difference between a
nook and a crayon chuck you have any
insight into it
yeah the nooks are not as delicious
okay
so but yeah everything is rough so what
you really want to do is you want to
increase the contact points as much as
possible if you want to get to to get to
touch the surface as much as possible so
like when you will see geckos and if you
see them in the wild they can climb on
everything you know they're running
across waxy leaves and wet rocks um
they can climb on glass they can be
inverted on sheets of glass which are a
material it's a material we think of as
really smooth but yeah as neil said on
the microscale it's not smooth it's very
rough and textured so these tiny hairs
can kind of get in there and they can
start it's it's a force called van der
waals interaction it's a force that you
can only tap into when atoms are close
enough together and that is what the
gecko uses like the gecko's foot is
effectively feeling for electrons
in the atoms of whatever the surfaces
that they're climbing what you're kind
of describing on an atomic level is
velcro
yeah
yeah to be honest it's very similar
although it's
and looking for a signal rather than
just you know
clasping together and pulling apart yeah
and that the thing that's even more
impressive about the geckos version of
this velcro is that it can detach really
quickly so you know when you're pulling
gecko or pulling geckos apart don't do
that
that's my favorite it's my favorite past
time by the way laurie are you
velcro apart you get that like really
loud noise and it takes quite a lot of
force but at gecko all the gecko needs
to do is it curls its toes back and that
changes the angle that those split ends
those hairs are making with the with the
surface
and that turns off its stickiness
instantly so geckos can turn on and off
their stickiness depending on the
orientation of their toes otherwise they
wouldn't be able to actually walk
exactly you place them down they just
get stuck stuck forever right yeah being
ultra sticky isn't that useful to be
honest like you want to be able to
turn it on when you need it and turn it
off when you want to scarper so yeah the
gecko like has all of these features
that are all working together to get
that contact at the atomic level at the
you know really talking about electrons
in order to decline so yeah they're
amazing
am i right here am i right here lori
where you get a gecko that may be a half
a pound or a pound in weight
right and you stick it to the ceiling
and then it can hold nearly 300 pounds
of weight now a how
a the question is broke down in two
parts a how and b
how on earth do you test that it can
hold that much weight without being
crawled to a gecko oh yeah unfortunately
there's a few geckos who gave their life
for that experiment yeah yeah
yeah this to be honest if you look back
at the early history of gekko research
there really are a lot of geckos that
were treated badly um but in terms of
this research it's really based on a
measurement taken on a single one of
those hairs and then they scale it up
to yeah i mean so it's kind of that's
why i say in theory right there's this
kind of a scaling question
and because you know really a gecko
shouldn't ever need to
you know be able to support that sort of
force why it's so good is because it's
not usually in a lab right like i said
it's usually running around in the
forest
i don't want the geico company to learn
about this because yeah like tv
commercials where that little geico
gecko is saving people
yeah oh no we don't want that right
right right right actually neil that's
kind of cool
all right laurie so here we go
i know we're going to get off of geckos
in a minute but i'm just fascinated
because we're talking about sticky so i
know we got to leave the get-go
however when you look at the design of
their anatomy
is that also to
displace not disperse
their weight so that they can do these
things you're talking about because it's
not a good question yeah they're like
super stretched out with a tiny little
skinny body totally they absolutely do
the whole animal has a role to play it's
not just its toes and like for a start
they kind of do jazz hands
when they're when they're trying to get
they try to balance out the forces as
much as possible so the non-dancers out
there jeff's hands are fully open palm
forward
all fingers spread
it's showtime folks
they'll do that so that their toes are
pointing in opposite directions so that
the forces are all spread out evenly
across all of their toes and a gecko can
very easily just cling with with the
single toe and they don't need all of
their toes to be perfectly engaged in
order to be able to collapse that's just
showing off
i know isn't it okay so now once once
we've because it's taken us basically
till the 21st century to really get a
grip on understanding what's keeping a
gecko glued to a wall or a ceiling i see
what you did there gary said get a grip
on this yeah thank you
and
i know these things aren't just thrown
together
we've mimicked that
and we we came up we being very smart
people not me came up with gecko tape
and we have actually gone into space
with things based on a gecko's feet that
yeah
what is this
it kind of came out of lab at stanford
and um what they've done is
they they know that it's it's not
possible we we do not have the ability
to recreate the level of complex
structure that a gecko has naturally
evolved on its toes but what they can do
is they can kind of take some of the
essential elements and kind of cheat a
little bit copy a little copy some of
that
and what it looks like really and i got
to play with some myself when i visited
it's it's a silicone rubber so a very
flexible gray rubber and if you look at
it it just looks quite rough but if you
look at it under a microscope it's
actually covered in tiny little wedges
so it's been patterned with these wedges
that are angled
and they're at a similar angle to the
site these hairs on a gecko's foot
so what they do is
you can apply that if you have that on
say like a robotic arm for something
you can bring that robotic arm up
against say a solar panel if you're on
the international space station
and you put the gecko tape up against
whatever it is you're trying to pick up
and you tug it down slightly there's
just a little button on there on the
system that's that causes those wedges
to splay out so again kind of tapping
into the same idea as the hairs although
much much larger than hairs they're not
quite as they don't make quite intimate
contact but because the gecko so special
it doesn't need to make quite such
intimate contact it can make a little
bit of it and it does it does enough so
and you can do that without using like
a suction cup which is usually how we
move big awkward things around you can
do it without using any electricity
there's a lot of grippers that we use
use electricity electrostatics to pick
stuff up and they don't have any
clamping forces you can actually pick up
very delicate things
just by putting this gecko tape the
silicone rubber onto the surface and
causing its wedges to kind of splay out
and forgive me but the first thing i
thought of when you were describing this
tape is a new arcade machine where you
want to get the toy inside the thing you
just because you can never get it right
you never get the card with the clamp we
get some of your tape we win and we're
getting all the time
oh yeah every time yeah all the toys are
coming home with me okay
this is amazing yeah so this is actually
used in space now yeah so it was it was
trialled um initially on the vomit comet
um and then it eventually went up on the
international space station i think it's
had several trials now on the
international space station to be used
as a as a low gravity gripper and
manipulator um
of our listeners because that's all it
will be what the vomit comet is
oh yeah so the vomit comet is one of
nasa's test facilities it's a plane
basically that flies in a parabolic um
path and it simulates well low gravity
for short periods of time so if you want
to test something out in low gravity
that's a good way to do it so or even
zero gravity right or zero gravity yeah
indeed if only i'd love to have a go in
the comment if anyone's listening and
yeah so it is it is being used and it's
actually already being developed and
used in on factories on earth as well so
they've commercialized some of these
grippers to be used in in robotic
systems to to pick up awkwardly shaped
objects
yeah wow it's pretty cool
that's more than cool so tell me about
so tell me about the
uh what happens if
water is between your thing and the
surface
usually because because water is like
the enemy of tape right yes if you could
tape wet nothing sticks anyway know how
yeah so what you're doing uh except for
flex seal tape i have to tell you i've
seen those it's good stuff
yeah water no water is a problem you're
right neil and the gecko has evolved to
cope with it because it's feed as well
as being amazing for gripping they're
also hydrophobic so those feet actively
repel water they push water out of the
way so that they could make
dry effectively dry contact with
whatever surface it's touching
and for the silicone tape again silicone
itself is hydrophobic so it tries to
repel water as much as possible it's not
perfect but wow it works so let me ask
you this is there any way to take this
type of technology and apply it to tires
because i could see so many applications
for
for a safety as a matter of fact there
was a show called speed racer when i was
a kid and one of them remember speed
racer you remember speed so you're going
to sing again aren't you you're going to
sing the pair of you are going to sing
oh my god
okay anyway
one of the things were these super
sticky tires that would allow the car to
ride on any surface and even stick to
the walls and of course that can't
happen but to not lose traction
because they actually stop nascar when
it rains
all right but we're going to do tires in
the next segment okay well then oh okay
well let's just do that wait wait let's
just
hold on to that but put a pin in that
yeah and
laura you can hang out we got two more
segments with you and this is just
amazing
i mean i i want to do the whole thing on
geckos but
we've seen the topics
and they come in different colors and
different sizes yeah they're adorable
they are wonderful little lizards damn
okay when we come back more star talk
sports edition with surface expert
laurie winklas
we're back star talk sports edition
we spent an entire segment talking about
gecko toes
but
as as as interesting as that is to a
naturalist
this is sports edition damn it and i
want to know
how
are we gonna put gecko feet
on rubber
for cars and
stuff car races can we go there uh gary
is that we can go anywhere we want we've
got gecko wheels let's lay down the
rubber on that we got lori winklas who's
an expert on gecko feet i know yeah
lauren is that on your business card
no it definitely does what are you
carrying around on your business card oh
my gosh but anyway i'm delighted you're
coming to us from new zealand uh
beautiful countryside i'm not the first
nor the last to say that and
um thank you for uh coming on the line
with us here uh
across the ocean
north
yeah so so gary take take all right so
here's something
that may or may not be in people's
thinking
but it's a wiki fact
tribology i'd never heard of it before
but it is the science and engineering of
interacting surfaces in relative motion
it includes the study and application of
the principles of friction now i hadn't
thought of that as a science but
tribology is what we have here in mind
why don't they call it frictionology or
something why they got to be obscure
about it because the ancient greeks got
there first and they've decided it's
tribology
all right that's true slickology would
be better there you go so have you ever
heard of that laurie uh yeah yeah so a
lot of the a lot of this book is about
tribology and the short version is like
it's the science of rubbing and
scrubbing that's how it's awesome
i love it which i love yeah
that sounded a little uh sexual there
lori that's awesome yeah well i mean
this entire chapter is on lubrication as
well chuck so yeah
selective opportunity for innuendo
all right all right all right none of
this is making the show all right we've
known and we and we've had shows on this
very topic
is that
professional auto racing
often in fact i might say all the time
leads automotive technologies with
innovations that ultimately filter their
way back to commercial vehicles and
but
we look at the tires
as far as it
you know i see all the rest of the
technology they're still using rubber
tires on the track
is that am i missing something there
what's either nascar or especially
formula one where the full rubber tire
is sticking out or ball bare what what
what are we just getting gecko when are
we getting gekko feet on our formula one
cars and listen if you think about it
when you look at racing slicks
okay they're they're kind of uh they've
got to be a significant weight factor to
the car
you know so
maybe that's something if you want to
lighten the load gecko feet tires would
be a great way to do it
yeah i mean it's a funny one the pro the
main problem with echo tape is that it's
not very robust so it's not actually
very good it wouldn't be very good under
the weight of like a formula one car or
even just the formula one tire like you
said um but i should say that they use
rubber because it also if it's designed
well enough and if the track is smooth
enough it also can tap into those same
forces the van der waals forces
um because like those big formula one
slick tires they can make a similar
intimate contact with a racetrack that a
gecko can make with a wall like
racetrack because they're soft at some
level right i mean that's why they're
called rubber right i mean they're yeah
they fill in the any little
microscopic gaps yeah exactly like
what's up baby this is your this your
tire
how you doing just trying to make a
little intimate contact
[Music]
when you've got a formula one race car
and i mean
people like lewis hamilton will
hammer the pedal down and this thing's
gone over 200 miles per hour yeah plus
with a formula one race track you've got
all sorts of curves bends i mean a tire
will go through all of these different
forces
deformation tor all the rest of it
how are you ensuring that it's still
able to tap into those van der waals
forces under all these distresses yeah
really good question um the main the
main there's two main ways that a tire
makes contact with the road and one of
them is the way that normal tires make
contact with the road which is kind of
what neil said it's about the rubber
rubber is this material called it's a
visco elastic material so it's something
a bit like a very viscous or sticky
fluid and an elastic solid so it kind of
sits somewhere in that range and what it
means is that tyre rubber flows into all
of those bumps and crevices and all of
the you know roughness on a racetrack
and as it flows it it makes a kind of a
frictional interaction and that is
mostly how tires work that's mostly how
like road tires will grip to the road
but formula one tires are usually flat
very very particular compounds of rubber
like particularly their stickiness their
uh viscosity has been very well defined
and and they're huge right this massive
surface area that makes contact with the
track the track is usually also very
smooth so it can also tap into that van
der waals interaction assuming the
rubber can can actually just flow
properly into the track now sometimes
you'll see a formula one driver and they
talk about this they talk about this
another motorsport too about laying down
some rubber right this idea of actually
like the tire degrading intentionally
formula one is totally based on that
those tires are designed to degrade
they're designed to leave tiny thin
layers of rubber on the track because
that increases the grip for the next
time you go around the track you lay
down the rubber to increase the friction
between your tire the next time you pass
by
but like on a normal car you do not want
your rubber to be degrading over the
course of a few kilometers right because
they changed their wheels in an f1 you
know
exactly
one tire it's like the cost i can't even
i don't even know how much it will go
yeah you don't have to change your
wheels on the way to you know to the
7-11 you know no
you know what chuck do you know when
you're talking about you want gecko
tires right gecko feet on on a tire
haven't have they larry done exactly
that because a formula one race will
take place in the rain
and they'll obviously then have a tread
pattern on the tyre yeah which then
disperses an awful lot of surface water
so are they using a similar sort of
technique that a gecko would for being
hydrophobic wait gary do they swap out
the tires when it rains yes they do okay
it's a different tire with uh oh they'll
have a whole team normally with a
channel through the middle of the tire
and then some kind of uh
some type of uh channeling that moves
the water away exactly the whole team to
manage to to manage the tire to manage
the setup of the car based on the
weather it could be continuity
temperature
i think this should happen also in snow
just to
yeah well
if you watch rally if you watch rally
they're they're racing on ice
which is just great no but they don't
have tire changes do they in really
rubber itself is a bit hydrophobic it is
it does repel water but really it's the
design of those tread patterns that
pushes the water out of the way so like
a formula one i think it's the 2020
formula one tires i need to check but um
they remove they can remove about 65
liters of water per second
when the car is moving at full speed
like the every single pattern on a tread
has been designed to suck the water up
and like chuck said kind of push it out
the sides of the tire so that the
contact is as dry as they can possibly
get it like there's a limits right
there's a limit so the tire is basically
a windshield wiper for the road
exactly a very expensive windshield very
expensive windshield wiper so my my
question then
is from a material standpoint
why not just do two things
one
increase the friction of the surface
upon which you're driving
and two
make it so that the tire becomes more
interactive with that
frictioned surface or that's that that
surface that has more friction
so let me tighten up chuck's question
please okay if if if the whole point is
to have rubber grip into the texture of
the track
why not actually
chew up the track
so that the rubber is getting so
in there it's not even about friction
it's actually pushing off of vertical
walls that have been cut into the track
as you go around yeah i think i think
the argument really is about you want to
keep this as a fast sport right and
friction you need some of it in order to
you know get the traction on the road to
to propel yourself forward so you do
need some friction but if it's too high
then your car has a very
much lower maximum speed right it
reduces how fast your car can go so
you've got this so this is the point of
equilibrium
yeah there's always a balance there's
always a compromise like you need some
but not too much and then if you're you
know if you're looking if you're looking
at like an ice sport like it like skiing
or something like that you're looking at
trying to minimize friction but it's
always you do need some but just not
everything because if you have too much
friction things just grind to halt
laurie about 50 years ago formula one
stumbled across a thing called carbon
carbon if i'm not mistaken um
and
since then it's been part of the space
shuttle
what's the connection
yeah carbon carbon is one of the
materials that's used a lot in formula
one because it's very very strong and
it's very very light
um and it's usually it's in formula
one's context it's used in breaks so
it's used as a
as a lightweight way to produce a strong
surface and that you can you know
interact with um and as with most things
you know they find applications
elsewhere i don't actually know which
one came first in terms of carbon carbon
whether it was developed specifically
for formula one or whether it came about
as a byproduct of of another industry
and but yeah it is very much a it is
very important material now wait lori
forgive me but can we be a little more
explicit than just saying carbon carbon
can you tell me like what the hell that
is
i've heard of duran duran and
no fair fight
new york new york new york new york
[Laughter]
sachi and sachi
yeah no no that's fair point so like if
you've heard of carbon fiber you might
have heard of that it's carbon you know
it's like long strands of carbon fiber
arranged in some sort of matrix some
sort of polymer but carbon carbon is
those carbon fibers that have been
arranged in a matrix of graphite so the
the actual matrix itself is carbon but
just little flakes of carbon and then
the fibers going through it are these
very aligned carbon fibers so it is
carbon and carbon in two different forms
so two different forms of carbon got it
so if you threw in like diamond you'd
have carbon-carbon carbon yeah yeah
exactly
just carbon cubes
and then as we found in the universe as
well as in the lab there's bucky balls
right carbon 60 another form of carbon
so just throw it all in there get carbon
carbon carbon carbon exactly formula one
has the money first really
sure
but they and they use that money to
do something that i think a lot of
people have been hoping to do for a long
time when they've got a curse system the
kinetic energy recovery system oh yeah
um and
how advanced was their thinking to be
able to bring that forward for
motorsport but we haven't seen it in the
the general public
you can see some you see a version of it
well yeah i have i have a regenerative
braking is that the same
yeah
it is the same thing once we started
putting electric motors into our cars
that that becomes something that you can
that's a really useful form of energy to
capture yeah capture and return to the
to the electric motor so what does it
hand it to a flywheel or something or is
it a
what what in what form is it
is it
recaptured as
and yeah and by the way you should
probably explain the whole concept
because clearly we're all familiar and i
feel like we're a little inside baseball
right now
um yeah so it's like
we're inside friction
baseball
well played sir well played
um yeah so the regenerative braking is
effectively when you put the brake on
you effectively turn your motor into a
generator so you flip it around you flip
around it's its uh
behavior and so it generates electricity
um so yeah in a formula one car i
believe it is just used in terms of
electricity it is just captured and used
elsewhere in the car but i'm actually
not sure so i won't pretend i know wait
wait just to be clear you said when you
put the brake on let me let me clarify
that what you mean is when you
press the brake pedal
brake pads are not touching your wheel
what's happening is the
forward motion of your car is getting
sucked away
yeah back
into
is isn't that what's happening yeah
that's it yeah that's that's it yeah
yeah so it's brilliant your kinetic
energy is getting absorbed without even
using friction in that sense yeah
yeah because usually breaks are just
about like
slamming on the friction as high as
possible flintstones
do they have flintstones in new zealand
i don't know
yeah i remember them as a kid though
yeah
yeah yeah that's the accelerator pedal
and the brakes yeah
big three-toed feet
they have four fingers and three toes
that disturbed me more than the fact
that they're living in the stone age
with do you know that this is the first
time that i have heard that and i and
you're right
you never noticed that i've never
noticed that oh my gosh i have to at
least give the man four toes to match
his four fingers
isn't there something about when the
animator draws a hand with four fingers
and a thumb it looks wrong and so that's
why they they take away one digit okay
so so so gary
four fingers never looked right to me
okay ever and especially not the three
toes with his big old caveman feet
but they make it we're gonna take a
break we're talking about generative
recovery
we're talking about friction we're
talking about formula one uh we got
rubber we got gecko feet all in one
freaking conversation go figure uh and
at the center all that is lori winkles
we'll be right back
we're back star talk sports edition
everything friction and surfaces with
one of the world's greatest
exponents of this subject that i have
ever seen lori winklas who's coming to
us from from new zealand lori thanks for
being on star talk and and illuminating
us
with all of your surface wisdom
uh my pleasure
so when someone says you know it's only
skin deep you're saying yeah
exactly
that's where the action is okay
so so we've talked about what you've
learned sort of scientifically from
mother nature
and at the end of the day stuff only
really happens if people can make money
off of it if there's sort of product
uh development applications that can
improve what we already have
or invent something new that we never
thought we needed
so do you have some good examples of
that maybe
yeah i'll give you one that it's still i
would say at the research end of the r d
scale but it's pretty exciting and
if it works it could give us boats that
never get wet which i think is pretty
cool
um
boats that never get wet they never get
wet no so wow
that's like charlie in the chocolate
factory square sweets that look round
yeah exactly you're precisely gary yeah
okay
yeah
so wait a minute let me let me just put
this out i mean let me take this through
if the boat never gets wet but it's
moving through water
then that's about as frictionless as you
could ever get yes
super fast boats is that right
yeah and you've got if you think about
the fact that like 90 of the world's
trade happens by sea
um if we could reduce the friction that
those massive container ships experience
as they move through the water you
reduce the amount of fuel they use you
improve the environmental you know
properties of that so that is like
something that a lot of different
technologies are attempting to do and
you can already get boats that you know
have a low friction coating on them
but one of the things i came across and
i thought was really cool is there's
this fern it's called a salvinia fern
and it's usually like an invasive
species it it forms these massive maps
on the surface of waterways so it can
often cause damage to anything living in
the waterway
but the cool thing about it is that it
is incredibly hydrophobic so
if you've heard of the lotus effect
which is this idea that the lotus is
always pristine water nothing sticks to
it nothing ever dirt doesn't touch it
it's kind of like that but way better
it's way more impressive um and when
scientists started to study what it is
that makes this plant so good at
repelling water
they started by looking at the surface
so in a way it's kind of gecko-like it's
covered in loads and loads of hairs and
each one of those hairs
is shaped a bit like a whisk right so
it's kind of got four
it breaks into four that points that
join at the
top the whole leaf and all of these
hairs are covered in a waxy surface
which makes it water repellent but the
cool thing is the very tip of that whisk
is not water repellent it's water
attracting it's hydrophilic it attracts
water
so what that means is that you trap a
layer of air the leaf traps a layer of
air in its hairs and because water is
pinned onto the top of each one of those
hairs the air can't get out and the
water can't penetrate in
so you have this permanent layer of air
that the leaf
has around itself
you're really explaining kind of a
microscopic hydrofoil
yeah well this is and this is where when
like when this when the botanists kind
of realize that this is what's going on
they managed to recreate it they managed
to kind of produce coatings that have a
similar structure this combination of
hydrophobic so water repellent and
hydrophilic water attracting and
capturing this this band of air so what
they want to do is develop a coating
that you could apply to a boat that
retains a layer of air around it
permanently a stable layer of air um and
there are some boats that have these
they produce bubbles like there's an
actual system that spreads out bubbles
around the edge of a boat to try and
reduce the friction in a similar way but
it's just not as stable as as something
that would be you know a solid layer of
air
i thought i remembered a t was it a tv
commercial i might have been you know
youtube surfing i think i was and i came
across
uh it was like a
container of mayonnaise and a container
of ketchup yes two famously
uh bottle-sticking substances yeah that
and they just tipped over the mayonnaise
and all the mayonnaise just came right
out of the container and they tipped the
ketchup bottle and all the ketchup just
came nobody was shaking it or pounding
it or squeezing it did it have one of
these surfaces that you're talking about
no it's actually got another surface
there's so many
you see now why i had to write a whole
book about them because they're just
amazing um yeah so that's a different
material actually and what it does is it
basically they have they put a coating
that's porous so it's got loads of holes
in it but then it's those holes are
filled with water so it's kind of using
water to stop other liquids from
sticking to it
so they've textured it in a way that
it traps its own little layer of of of
water so that the ketchup then just
falls out of the maintenance just to
show you how biased we are just as
members of civilization i'm looking at
that demo and i'm thinking what's wrong
with the ketchup exactly you know i'm
not eating that ketchup yeah i'm
thinking it's a ketchup issue not a
surface issue that's what i'm thinking
to myself because it doesn't look a bit
creepy it looks creepy yeah it's it's
you know it looks good cancer is
supposed to god make ketchup to stick to
the inside of the
that's
body
seeing peanut butter slide out
that's wrong if you ever saw a peanut
butter slide out of anything other than
run walk don't run
away that peanut butter is sentient okay
when you talk about
so your surfaces that slip and slide
is there anything that can make
something more aerodynamic like you put
a coating on a football and now
you know instead of being able to throw
it 30 yards i can throw it 50 yards or
kick it more more importantly
yeah yeah good point and actually that's
kind of where like golf balls came from
as well because the original golf balls
were were smooth
and they were made from um basically
they pack loads a ball of leather with
these feathers make it really really
hard smooth surface but they realized
that the ball would travel further when
it had been dinged up a bit so when it
had some like dents in it
so there was a scientist who designed a
pattern which is now what we know as a
golf ball pattern this dimpled pattern
and that reduces the drag on a golf ball
by playing with the way that
the air flows around us and and the
formation of these little vortexes these
little areas of low pressure and
that that dimple pattern kind of makes
it plays around with turbulence and in
order in a way to reduce drag so like a
dimpled ball will travel about about
twice as far as a smooth golf ball of
the same dimension so it's really
traveling in its own pocket
of of low friction air is that a fair
way to say that yeah like everything
moving through the air has a layer of
kind of stuck air molecules right on its
surface and as the air as you get
further away from the surface the air
moves more and more and more you know
air sticks to me all the time
exactly it's detained it's so sticky you
don't even know what i was thinking that
way
is that is that the sort of thing that's
going on with an aircraft say that was
flying at 30 000 feet the temperature
outside the air temperature outside is
minus something silly
yeah yeah and yeah
yeah and yet there's a an issue for
overheating what what are we
experiencing
with that yeah it's exactly that is skin
friction so it's effectively the air
molecules bashing into other air
molecules that are stuck onto the
surface of of the aircraft and even
though at
many it depends on the altitude of
course but the density of air can be
lower than it is on this on the surface
of the earth there's still plenty of air
molecules to bash into one another so
the
moving especially at 500 miles an hour
right yeah exactly moving through the
air at high speeds you are causing
massive transfers of kinetic energy you
know you are caught you are bashing air
molecules out of the way like crazy and
in that process you lose some some of
that kinetic energy transforms into heat
energy transforms into that the high
temperatures on the surface so like a
lot of the very very high speed
aircrafts are and like re-entry vehicles
they've been designed their their
surface chemistry has been really
particularly designed to be able to cope
with that happening on their surface
that's why you know heat heat and
shields are so important i mean we've
discussed surfaces
contacting each other but we haven't
discussed how we
as humans interact
with surfaces particularly through our
own skin
what what happens at a molecular level
when we are touching and feeling
surfaces and how do i become spider-man
with my own form of gecko feet
well yeah this is a there's a dude i
think he's at san diego uh university
chuck who could sort you out he
developed a climber based on the gecko
tape so he managed to scale the building
well a few stories of a building on his
own
but it is true however there are some
things um
you know sometimes i don't know it
depends on how oily or not your skin is
there could be something on a on a on
the ground that you just touch it and it
stick like a playing card maybe will
stick to your finger sometimes a penny
might stick to your finger yeah um
some light little things will stick to
your finger but i don't want to claim
gecko powers
so what's going on with that when that
happens
it's basically that we're a bit damp
i thought it was going to be a deep
explanation
unfortunately not just that
we're sweaty yeah
we just have water on us and uh usually
that's enough to you get an effect via
capillary force the the water that are
you know we are producing water all the
time we respire and so we are constantly
covered in a little very thin layer of
water and sometimes that means that we
can you know stick a spoon to our nose
or we can pick up a piece of paper just
by touching it
i thought it was the vaccine that made
that happen
thought it was the vaccine just like got
vaccinated look at me i'm magnetic now
uh
i don't know who's gonna fix this
all right laurie before before we
we have to let you go sadly um
we i mean be thrilled by the gecko i
think we all have um are there anymore
can you join the show can you be sure
are there any other species out there
that are kind of like
owning it
like the gecko yes
[Music]
wait a minute why would a shark need to
grip anything oh shoot we'll just talk
about
go on laurie yeah no don't mind chuck
just ignore him
sharks are incredible and if you look at
their skin uh and you don't even have to
have a particularly fancy microscope
don't do this to a living shark right
i'm talking about like a museum
don't touch a shark
but their skin is covered in these
features called dermal identicals and
they're like very tiny um
scales they're kind of like scales but
they're actually 3d they're they're a
real structure
and what scientists have realized is
that we kind of knew that the shape and
the placement of those tentacles all
over a shark's body must have something
to do with reducing drag it must have
something to do with making it easier
for them to move through the water but
what scientists realized in more recent
years is that what's happening with
these dermal identicals is that on some
parts of a shark's body it's
it's the flow of water around this
tentacle
actually
behaves in a way as if it's gone in
reverse
so it's as if the water is actually
pushing the shark forward it's not just
reducing drag it's actively helping the
shark to accelerate through the water so
the shark is drafting itself yeah
that is unbelievable yeah okay but wait
a minute
let's let's bring in some evolution here
because no i got a question
uh i you know i i can't claim to have
hung out with sharks okay so i don't
know
of what i say speak but
i don't picture
sharks
uh in heist pursuit of their prey
i picture them
stalking their prey yeah right and and
so
why would speed
have been selected for in their skin
water
surfaces if that's not really what
they're doing
very good point and
they i think the kind of the idea around
it now is that these tentacles have a
different role to play on different
parts of the body so there are different
sizes and shapes depending on and they
differ between species of sharks as well
so some sharks are more of it
they're more about speed they're more
about reducing drag but in terms of
increasing speed and reducing drag
really what that does is it decreases
the amount of energy a shark needs to
use to push its way through the water
and importantly importantly because
sharks have to move in order to breathe
you would want that to you would like
that easy as as easy as possible yeah
because when you do need to go hunt
you you haven't used up all your energy
swimming around so you can breathe
because i just know that if sharks were
fast-moving
chase you down the meat predators then
you couldn't have that slow cello
in
jaws
you know that that that that there's a
cello or a base uh
yeah
it's a cell so whichever it is it's like
that's not the music you hear of
something rapidly chasing something else
no so it all worked out mm-hmm it all
worked out for the movie yeah and by the
way
we're gonna need a bigger boat
chuck you know i thought you were above
that chuck
i
got the lowest hanging fruit
was already on the ground if you ever
mentioned jaws i have to say that i
can't i have to
it's a law
so lori we gotta i think we gotta close
this out uh do you have a social media
we can track you down on yeah i'm on
twitter like way too much so i'm at lori
underscore winkless and your books tell
me the titles again they were so great
yeah so uh sticky is just out it's
literally just came out a month ago in
the u.s and so sticky the secret science
of services and my older book is
um science and the city and that's all
about how cities work and
and what happens in the in the
metropolis this is beautiful i love it i
love it and what are you working on now
what can we in the future because we
totally want to bring you back so give
us an excuse to bring you back
um well what i'm working on right now is
an article on chocolate making physics
of chocolate making which is something
i'm finding quite interesting um but
i've noticed can we book you tomorrow
by the way by the way can we uh can we
uh can we do some research for you yeah
yeah i'll send you some examples okay
nothing else immediate no no more books
in the immediate pipeline anyway take a
break for a little while
we got to end it there so
gary chuck always good to have you doing
this pleasure all right and lori it's
been a delight to have you on this
program we learned so much about
stuff we didn't even know there was
something to learn about so that's
always a good day uh
at least for me and i'm sure for
thanksgiving
oh super fun i listened to the show so
it's really fun to
do okay
excellent excellent i hope we lived up
to your expectations very much you
certainly exceeded ours so
all right this has been star talk sports
edition neil degrasse tyson as always
bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]